[Music]
on this Tuesday night Israel's dire
prediction for its war against Hamas as
more blood is
shed this war has necessary and not easy
goals to achieve plus what Israel is now
denying to un workers and why the
struggle to own a home what economists
say is needed to raise
affordability high-tech help for
healthcare how doctors nurses and
patients could benefit from artificial
intelligence plus five Decades of
frightening audiences and spinning
heads what inspired The Exorcist and how
it revolutionized the horror
genre global national with G of freezen
reporting tonight meu
Gara good evening and thanks for joining
us we are less than a week away from the
new year yet there are no signs the
crisis in the Middle East after Hamas
attack on Israel on October 7th is any
closer to being
[Music]
resolved today Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu warned Hamas that
Israel has fighters on the ground
sometimes underground and eyes in the
sky as their Siege on Gaza continues
that they will fight until the end with
the help of the most advanced technology
this is despite the already staggering
level of Destruction and suffering in
Gaza from the assault with more than
20,000 Palestinians killed according to
its Hamas run Health Ministry on Monday
Egypt presented its own proposal for a
permanent ceasefire it would see all of
hamas's hostages released in return for
Israel freeing more Palestinian
prisoners but Hamas rejected the plan
which also conflicted with Israel's
goals of eradicating the Armed group and
as Redmond Shannon reports in our top
story tonight there are more signs the
Region's instability could grow E even
wider the season of goodwi in the holy
land where Despair and death
persist Israel's bombing and ground
campaigns claim more lives in Gaza and
displace more
gazans this woman says Israel should
confront resistance Fighters not
civilians like her family member Israel
insists it does not Target civilians
Hamas figures say more than 20,000
people have been killed since October
7th Israel's defense minister says Gaza
is one of seven fronts on which Israel
is now
fighting there is the occupied West Bank
the skirmishes against Hezbollah in
Lebanon and actors in Iran Iraq Syria
and
Yemen you have an says Israel has taken
action on six of those seven fronts he
did not elaborate but it's a strong
suggestion from Israel that it has
struck against iranian-backed targets
inside Iraq or Yemen or possibly Iran
itself Iran meanwhile has vowed revenge
for Monday's suspected Israeli air
strike in Syria that killed this senior
Iranian Commander also the un's atomic
energy agency said Tuesday Iran is
reversing its decision to slow down its
enrichment of uranium and in neighboring
Iraq the United States bombed targets
after recent attacks on its air bases in
Iraq and Syria the simmering tensions in
the region are doing little to help any
Prospect of Peace in Gaza and Israel's
government is increasingly frustrated
with what it sees as a lack of support
from the International Community now
saying it will no longer automatically
Grant visas to United Nations workers
for too long International officials
have been deflecting blame onto Israel
to cover up for the fact that they are
covering up for Hamas in failing to
condemn Hamas for hijacking Aid and
failing to condemn it for Waging War out
of hospitals they have been complicit
Partners in hamas's human shield
strategy and the head of Israel's Armed
Forces echoed Monday's statement from
Prime min Mr Benjamin Netanyahu hery
halevi told Israeli journalists that the
war will continue for many months n
Redmond Shannon in London thanks
Redmond Ukraine has claimed
responsibility for an attack on a
warship in Russia controlled Crimea
overnight killing at least one
person Ukrainian military officials say
they fired cruise missiles to destroy
the large Landing ship Russia's defense
Ministry says the vessel which can
transport tanks armored vehicles and
troops was only damaged it's the latest
in a series of attacks on Russia's Black
Sea Fleet in Crimea throughout its
invasion of
Ukraine and in Russia one of the
president's loudest critics is sounding
off on social media after weeks of worry
about his sudden disappearance Alexi
naly confirms he's now in a penal colony
north of the Arctic Circle joking his
new location makes makes him the new
Santa Claus the move to one of Russia's
toughest prisons took what navali calls
an exhausting 20 days but he says he's
fine he's serving sentences totaling
more than 30 years on extremism and
misdemeanor charges which are widely
criticized as
bogus back in this country with
Christmas now over many Canadians are
looking to take advantage of this
holiday season's last Bargains for
boxing day it's another welcome but
brief reprieve as consumers compl laain
about Rising retail prices sha OA takes
a look at how deal hungry Shoppers fared
across the
country it's an annual Canadian ritual
Boxing Day shopping and in a year where
a lot of people have been feeling
Financial strains The Lure of discounts
is an excuse for many to seek Bargains
people like Bargains people like to get
something where they think they're
getting a great price and so it it is a
way to get people into stores and one of
the things is that when you get people
into stores they tend to buy more
malls across the country Boxing Day
sales are seen as a last chance to get
The Season's best deals many consumers
uh were disappointed with the Black
Friday and Cyber Monday deal so they
will definit be looking for deeper
discounts that's what we looking for
hopefully but whatever if they like it
and it makes sense we get it the hunt to
make their dollars go farther some of
the deals that we're going to look for
are maybe things that are like 50% off
like I want to see the big deals some
are finding that did you get a good deal
yeah yeah a good deal yeah uh it's
around like like 50% off in Montreal
others were disappointed not as cheapest
I was expecting but when you're spending
money that's a gift it's a different
story I did just get some birthday money
so I feel more inclined to spend my
money in Alberta where there's no
provincial sales tax dollars get
stretched a little farther people really
seem to just be in a in great spirits
and great mood and this season retail
Watchers say there's a move back to inor
shopping away from online we really
think that there's been all this push
about the demise of the brick and mortar
store and that everybody is shopping
online but we are actually seeing a real
comeback I like always like Personal
Touch with the people at the same time
you can feel the product with so many
sales leading up to Christmas boxing day
doesn't have the same Allure it once did
but experts say it's still key to
retailers especially hoping to move
winter merchandise when it's still cold
outside Shan oay Global News
Toronto one of the reasons behind all
that bargain hunting Canadians are
spending more on housing it now takes
63% of median family income to own a
home in Canada that's much higher than
the 30% that most Financial experts
consider affordable it's a problem that
has attracted all sorts of new programs
and spending announcements to increase
the housing Supply but as McKenzie gray
tells us the factors leading to the
spike in shelter costs are not easy to
fix it's a complaint around the
Christmas dinner table the skyrocketing
cost of housing in a new report from
Canada's largest bank outlines just how
unaffordable home ownership is across
the country it actually reached like the
the highest level ever and as measure
against uh households income RBC
crunched the numbers and only 26% of
Canadian households can afford to
purchase a single family home 45% could
opt for a condo but when you break it
down regionally the picture looks even
worse in big cities in Vancouver it
would take 102% of the median Canadian
income to be a buyer in Toronto it's 84%
and even in famously affordable Montreal
it takes over 50% of a regular salary to
get into the market and there's only a
few ways that will change what we'll
need is significantly lower um interest
rate we need prices to uh at least
stabilize if not decline over the coming
uh uh months but a drop in house prices
in major markets seem unlikely the
Canada mortgage and housing Corporation
reporting new housing construction
dropped 22% in November and it's poised
to Trend down in the New Year we're
starting to see even those big projects
now slowing down quite a lot so I think
we should probably see starts uh being
impacted by that context while Supply is
dropping demand for housing is at its
highest level in decades a new report
from the Bank of Canada estimates an
additional
200,000 homes 10 months worth of Supply
needs to be built on top of current
levels just to keep up with Canada's
rocketing temporary immigration
admissions these two issues have been
increasingly tied together and there is
obviously a correlation we need to look
at the Liberals have announced new
housing measures to build just over 1
million new units but that commitment is
spread out over 10 years in the short
term Canada's population grew by a
staggering 430,000 from July to setember
alone that's like adding a city the size
of Victoria in just 3 months I think
people can expect further steps in the
new year to curb that another factor to
likely be reigned in interest rates with
most big Banks projecting Cuts starting
in the middle of 2024 which should make
housing costs more affordable but even
then RBC projects new buyers will have
to spend upwards of 50% of their income
to get into the housing market Mackenzie
Greg Global News Ottawa Rising on the
right coming up what federal
conservative leader Pierre PV might have
to do to maintain his growing
popularity police in Denver say they're
investigating incidents directed at
Colorado Supreme Court Justices and
providing extra patrols around their
homes following the Court's decision to
remove former president Donald Trump
from the state's presidential primary
ballot the FBI confirms it's involved as
as well and would vigorously pursue
investigations of any threat or use of
violence no other details are being
released Pierre PV and the conservatives
started the year tied in the polls with
Justin Trudeau and the Liberals now the
opposition leader is finishing with a
commanding
lead so what does bring it
home mean to
me PV released a new video on social
media today it's his latest attempt to
connect with v voters our chief
political correspondent David Aken looks
at how PV has built support and what he
needs to do to keep it in
2024 thank you and I welcome your
questions he bristles at some questions
actually you're wrong are you a CP and
prefers speaking directly to voters
who's ready for some common
sense either at the dozens of rallies he
held in 20123 across the country or via
video distributed on social media
platforms a lot of people would would
say that you're simply taking a page out
of the Donald Trump uh like which people
would say that Pierre pov's Okanogan
apple orchard interview went viral as
did this online video 15 minutes long on
Canada's housing crisis which PV
narrated an entire generation of Youth
now say they will never be able to
afford a home this is not normal for
Canada however he did it it has paid off
in voter support sure they talk about
other stuff here and there but for the
most part they're super focused and
they're super simple in their message
they've definitely shown uh willingness
to innovate and just try different types
of social media and different types of
videos uh which is just a good thing you
want to see from an opposition party the
conservatives finished 2023 with a
commanding double-digit lead in the
polls having raised more money through
the year than all other parties combined
and POV himself was named newsmaker of
the Year by the Canadian press the very
news organization he goes out of his way
to taunt Everything feels broken in
Canada but of course un there may not be
an election until the fall of
2025 that's a long time for the
conservatives to maintain the momentum
built in
2023 it's not people have cast a ballot
for him yet so they could certainly
change their minds just as easily as
they have moved towards his Direction
and I think that's um you know the risk
that he faces over there next year like
we saw with with the CP journalist
recently like we seen in in other ways
where he just gets like um uh he has
those little snide comments um in the
house or or in scrums or whatever it is
um those parts are what'll get them in
trouble one way the conservatives can
maintain momentum in 2024 is by
nominating so-called star candidates
Steven Harper did that ahead of the 2005
election Justin Trudeau did it in 2015
bringing on the likes of Christa
Freeland and Bill morno adding some
bigname candidates to ped's team is
likely the party's Next Step As It
prepares for 2025 David Aken Global News
Ottawa modernizing medicine ahead how
Healthcare is embracing artificial
[Music]
intelligence many Industries are
starting to take advantage of artificial
intelligence including including
medicine doctors say the technology can
help improve patient care and be a
Difference Maker in life or death
scenarios Katherine Ward explains how
Canada's largest network of research
hospitals is incorporating AI into its
workflow Chief AI scientist Bo Wang is
on a quest to figure out how to maximize
artificial intelligence to help patients
I see that when it comes to AI for
healthcare the keywords is not
replacement the keywords is in m one new
language learning model Wang has been
working on is a chat GPT like tool
called clinical camel once I ask this
question uh the clinical chemel will
process uh this information and uh uh
respond with the most accurate response
it can generate it's not meant to
replace doctors but rather to support
them we can use clinal camo to improve
doctor's uh workflow deficiency and
really reduce the burnout for doctors
and nurses Dr shaf kav G is a thoracic
surgeon and appreciates how AI could
reshape medicine if it could listen to
your conversation unjumble it and put it
in a structured clinical note and not
miss any important points or maybe
remind you that you forgot an important
Point can you remember to ask that then
you've saved me 15 20 minutes on each
patient I see that's huge Wang is also
looking at how to leverage AI for
medical imaging
instead of a technician manually
isolating elements on a scan AI could do
this more quickly they can segment all
the organs of Interest or tumors Nan
with accurate measurements within
seconds surgeons at Uhn are also using
algorithms to help determine if an organ
is viable for transplant only 20% of
lungs that are available from donors
worldwide are actually transplanted so
80% are not transplanted because we
don't know we can't be sure enough that
it's okay and while there are concerns
about privacy and misuse these experts
say charting a responsible Way Forward
is Paramount it's like a
scalpel you use it precisely but it can
do a lot of damage and I want to be part
of the solution not turning our back on
it saying how do we harness this and how
do we do it safe Katherine Ward Global
News the puck has dropped at the world
junior hockey championship in Sweden and
Canada's gold medal defense is off to a
great start plays it back for lamber on
the shot re score they got true C and
Canada up with the scoring Canada
grabbed the lead early and never let go
ending the night with a 5-2 win over
Finland to open the tournament Canada's
next game is against lava
tomorrow horror hisia next how The
Exorcist took the World by storm 50
years ago
[Music]
it's the power holy
water it's the power of Christ that
compin
you exactly 50 years ago today the film
that redefined fright The Exorcist hit
the big screen and sent movie goers into
a frenzy Jackson prco reports on the
real life story and places that inspired
what's still considered the greatest
horror movie of all
time this is the very real corner of
Washington DC that inspired one of the
scariest movies ever made The Exorcist
who lives and reigns with the father and
the Holy Spirit
Daven the 1973 film changed everything
about what we consider horrifying with
the story of a little girl possessed by
a demon and saved by a Catholic priest
performing a sacred right it's good
against evil and it's a demon being
driven out and it's horrible things that
are happening to this girl and
terrifying effects and you totally just
buy into this good against evil and you
know the light against the dark Matt
Lage hosts the scary movie Project
podcast everything was new right all
that stuff was new no one had seen a
real horror like that before right he
takes Exorcist fans on tours of the
film's famous
like the Epic Steps From the film's
final
scene after 50 years this place is still
incredible I mean even if you haven't
seen this film you know what these
stairs are you know what this place is
at the top of those long stairs there's
the actual house that was modified for
the film what they did was they built a
facade a taller roof on top and they
also built a fake front facade to come
out this way The Exorcist is still
drawing sellout houses for but what
people may not realize is that 50 years
ago The Exorcist Inspired Real fear I
fainted like 10 minutes after the first
beginning of the movie news reports were
filled with distraught filmgoers my legs
are just going who fainted in the aisles
and became ill during the movie remember
what scene it was it affected you so
much convulsions when she took
convulsions cuz I have a little girl
Toronto's University theater kept police
on standby to make sure no miners saw
the film Exorcist hysteria gripped the
Catholic church and the public and it's
so powerful and it becomes a real
message because it's just this awful
evil being done to this poor little girl
mother so much of the Fright Factor came
from a plot that almost seemed plausible
based on this 1949 Washington Post story
about a boy reported held in the devil's
grip that story was the basis for the
book and the screenplay written by
William Peter blatty a student at
Georgetown University a Jesuit school
where much of the film is set blatty
wrote this because of this setting right
he knew what he was writing he and he
knew he wanted it here The Exorcist went
on to make history as the first horror
movie nominated for the best picture
Academy Award hey where did this come
from adjusted for inflation it was the
highest grossing Warner Brothers film
until the release of Barbie there were
multiple sequels and imitators the
original is still the fan
favorite do you think it holds up 50
years later I think it absolutely holds
up we're standing here right now about
it aren't we sure enough fans kept
showing up to snap pictures of those
famous stairs take me a film that scared
or perhaps scarred a generation of movie
goers still turns heads half a century
later Jackson prco Global News
Washington it certainly dies I can say I
was too young when I first watched that
one that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm ncha tonight's your candada
is this pair of wolf dogs in Cochran Al
Berta thanks so much for watching
Colleen Christie will be at the anchor
desk tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night